have no fear the Wonder Woman of cheese
is here and she's going to share with us
how not to have your pre-dinner snacks
be abort as well as the Perfect Pairings
for Thanksgiving it's Diana Breyer from
belly season one well how are you so
good to have you my friend I love this
spread gift Thanksgiving turkey is the
star but I'll be honest I don't really
like turkey that much so you have some
perfect options to kind of get the party
started I do so one of the things that
I'm the most known for is snacking while
cooking yes I love that so really really
important to have like a really nice
sort of spread going on not only to
entertain your guests but to impress
them also to just have some bellies be
full while you're cooking or these
actually end up being perfect
accompaniments to your Thanksgiving Day
dinner so we have a couple of options
that we've brought here this is a
beautiful cheese and charcuterie platter
from Valley cheese and wine you actually
can call us you can contact us you can
do it online and you can say to us I'm
having this this this and this for my
Thanksgiving dinner just put cheeses
that'll go with it and we're happy to do
that and I love that you know that so
what what have you actually have you
paired this with like a Thanksgiving
kind of dinner here yes so we actually
have paired we have like your
Thanksgiving needs completely covered
this year yeah we have a Thanksgiving
wine package which includes champagne a
Chardonnay for your side dishes a Pinot
Noir for your turkey and a port for your
desserts wow and then this cheese board
is paired with it so that all the cheese
all the wine everything actually
beautifully and seamlessly integrates
into your holiday meal but can be
enjoyed anytime throughout the evening
so even while you're eating you can take
a little bit of this a little bit a
little bit of gruyere a little bit of
Pinot try this Pinot from Oregon you
know that's my favorite wine Diana knows
this tell us a little bit about this one
which one is it so this is the resonance
Pinot Noir from Oregon it's normal I'm
at Ava it is a beautiful beautiful
single Vineyard it's got a nice
Burgundian sort of classic style of wine
making to it so you'll find some earthy
characteristics but it's still going to
be nice and clean nice minerality like
you get from that sort of Pacific
Northwest style of wine making that is
beautiful with your turkey this year oh
my gosh that really is it's not so heavy
like maybe a cab would be but it is just
oh it felt so nice yeah you want to have
a wine that's really drinkable for
dinner because you don't want to be too
full too fast on too many different
things oh this is delicious these are
all designed to pair just exactly with
your side dishes it's a Thanksgiving
wine bundle it's also available online
it just takes all the guesswork out of
everything for you if you need to bring
a host for a gift we have that too a
little champagne paired with a double
cream Brie some apricot jelly and some
crackers these are less than a hundred
dollars so you can grab these and go
bring it be like be the host with the
most or just the best guest it's a
One-Stop shop I'm telling you you can
have your cheese and cookies all the
time and you gotta stop it how do people
order and where can they find you Valley
cheese and wine.com is a beautiful
website that we have been really working
hard on lately so you are able to
basically pre-order your cheese and
charcuterie boards pre-order your
Thanksgiving wine and pre-order bread
for my friends at 5098 bread who are
going to be their Thanksgiving morning
for you cheers cheers as well thank you
so much for having me thank you so much